[Music]
homie look what I become
all right here we go episode 260 home
team we haven't done one for a minute
time you've been out of time we've had a
bunch of different things going on but
we're together here with the biz doc
thanks for having me back Vinnie oshana
sauce Rob Malik we got everybody in the
house today it's just a special one that
we got we got a lot of stories to go
through one thing I know for a fact
everybody in the east coast today uh uh
who has an iPhone woke up at 4 45 a.m I
know that I don't know if you guys had
an amber alert or not did that happen to
you as well it was a test what
I go on Twitter to think if it's like a
thing on my phone it's like no everybody
did you just get an amber alert at 4 45
you know can you imagine a test you do
like there's a time for death like
exactly I woke up look at my phone here
and it says this is a test the emergency
broadcasting system I'm like I'm in
favor of that but then I put my glasses
on and said
I think it's pretty good broadcasting
the bigger question is do any of you
guys sleep with your phone ringer on no
but I'm saying like still go to bed turn
it off do not disturb everything okay I
sleep with do not disturb it's Amber
Alert still ghosts that's correct yeah
oh yeah my phone I don't care if there's
a nuclear listen I got no I got four uh
alarms in my house yeah and two
additional ones in the middle then I
when they want to lick themselves these
two dogs we've got six alarms that wake
us up but at a seventh one yesterday
with Amber Alert which was exciting by
the way yesterday we went and we shut
down a movie theater the whole valley
timing team 65 of us we watch the air
what a freaking movie what a movie
amazing yes or no I cried I got I got
like motivated I got it was it was
amazing maybe one of the best
motivational scenes ever in a movie I
think so when he's selling Michael and
the family I'm going with Nike if folks
if you haven't seen this movie watch it
air if you run a business team if you
run a sales team if you've got an
organization if you're a leader of a
pack if you got kids that are
competitive go watch it with them trust
me there's going to be a lot of value
from this I've already watched it twice
in four days and in two weeks we're
shutting down a theater in Dallas to
watch it with 300 people to watch air
again it's that that epic of a movie The
acting was amazing the soundtrack the
music oh the best actor though by far
was the guy that played the shoe Jordan
the guy that played Michael Jordan yeah
he had no lines he had no face it was a
silhouette the epitome of like
entrepreneurs that designed a shoe was
by far the best he was hilarious
yes tip of the hat to Ben Affleck
because if you liked Argo he took a real
story brought that to life and he's done
it again here and so um I like his
outfit he reminded me of Adam the way he
was running out can you go in pink room
and by the way that that is Phil
Knight's Persona by the way yeah the
running outfit with the shorts and
the shoe dog right that's the book yeah
exactly okay let's go through some
stories we got a lot of stories today
that we got to cover one there's this
thing about Dominion Fox had to pay 787
million dollars we have to cover this
today whoopsie uh next lesson half
Americans are on track for comfortable
retirement we may cover that double uh
public pessimism on the economy hits a
new high uh Amazon is slashing another 9
000 more workers amid a layoff wave that
has expanded past Tech to include uh
bellwethers like Dao and 3M okay mosca
says we need a normal person for
president 2024 if you know that person
let us know we're looking for him as
well uh Trump posts on Instagram for the
first time I don't know if you guys saw
it or not there's a lot of uh why would
that be the first post the Santas try to
buy her
now she's helping Trump to bury her okay
it's an interesting one Chris Christie
calling out everybody turns into
DeSantis and Trump as he eyes 2024 here
are all the Republican candidates we'll
cover that uh people are working in the
office spend 25 more time on their
Career Development we got a bunch of
different things musk had something to
say about Zuck maybe we'll play that
clip Florida is home of four out of the
five largest metro areas with the lowest
ready unemployment okay New York's
Exodus the pro-business is not slowing
down there's a Biden poll that just came
out that's not good Joe Rogan just said
I would vote for Donald Trump he opposes
Biden's cabinet running the world's most
powerful country and we got AOC not
happy with a couple decisions the mayor
made and then Megan Kelly lost her mind
on Dylan Mulvaney you have to see this
video it's something else okay so Tom
let's go right into economy
in some business stories uh let's let's
talk about public pessimism on the
economy hits a new new high this is a
CNBC story page four
if you want to go to it so uh uh so the
latest CNBC All-American economic survey
revealed that 69 of Americans have
negative views about the economy both
now and in the future which is the
highest percentage in the survey 17 year
history about two-thirds of Americans
say their wages are falling behind
inflation and two-thirds say the nation
is headed for recession in already or
and already won already in one Joe Biden
handling of the economy has received a
disapproval from 62 percent of Americans
a deterioration from US 58 57 percent to
38 margin in the last survey which is
the second worst reading of his
presidency on the economy his overall
rating fell by two percentage points to
39 and his disapproval rating Rose by a
point to 55 compared to the November
survey Biden lost support from several
key groups including Democrats and
independents Tom thoughts well there's a
couple sides of the economy the Market's
doing well we'll talk about that a
little bit later oils is going to make a
rebound we'll talk about that later but
right now we're talking about people and
let's take it down to people I usually
go macro and then Adam comes in talks
about consumer and people but I'm gonna
talk about people what people are saying
individuals is all of these layoffs and
the long-term effects six percent
inflation doesn't sound big until it's
been going on for 18 months in at six
percent six percent six percent it
starts getting you
the average Americans right now are
saying that wait this is now really
pinching me layoffs have now touched
somebody I know layoffs have touched my
nephew my cousin you know what this
economy is not helping me and all the
spin that the White House was putting on
it was keeping people aligned but now
you even have Democrats and independents
saying to Biden hey wait a minute man
this isn't spin this isn't transitory
and so things are shifting and so people
are being impacted by layoffs uh food
prices especially have not retreated SO
gas price at the pump you know bounce
around a lot eggs don't do that they get
there and they kind of stay there and
like the price of food products kinds of
you know ends up staying there so the
average American right now pbd is
hurting and now they're voicing it and
it's coming out in surveys that the
administration and others cannot put the
public spin on and say oh well it's just
transitory it's not that bad the average
person is saying wait a minute I'm
getting squeezed and I'm feeling it I'm
feeling it worse I'm feeling it long
term and now the the real savings rate I
don't know if I can retire these are now
high level concerns it's not just it's
tough right now it's like do I have
enough to retire and what's going on and
I bought by the way my nephew has moved
in with me and I can't get him off my
couch yeah in fact I mean sorry Tom you
didn't know that's going to affect like
voting when it comes down to the
election like is that going to be one of
the key things that they're going to
talk about whoever's going to be going
again this is not going away and to
quote Bill Clinton economy stupid yeah
no no it's real yeah
when building Bill did that he was
pointing something out against all of
the Bush senior strategy that they
missed and that went right to the heart
of America and that same thing that Bill
said is true right now and it's getting
worse great I think uh
I always say this there's things that
matter and there's things you can't
control I mean it's the perfect
juxtaposition just on this page if
you're looking at it right now public
pessimism on the economy hits a new high
got it we just covered that story uh
Larry Summers former Economist Fed chair
at one point or he was a secretary of a
treasury uh Larry Summers 70 70 chance
of a recession then you got BlackRock
Larry Fink saying no big recession
headed for the economy which one is it
do a coin flip I think we can all feel
the writing on the wall that something
is happening we understand something's
happening but what can you do about it
this Monday was tax day right well I
think it got extended uh two days
Tuesday so Monday you had to get in by
midnight to exactly but it's tax season
right now so when you do get your refund
two grand five grand 10 grand
maybe you don't go on vacation this
summer maybe you don't ball out at the
mall this summer I don't know maybe you
understand hey let me save that money
what is that job loss no it's 20 billion
left 20 billion lessons on your point
gotcha thank you yeah so uh
during covid there was free money flying
around you know cash is trash uh nfts
were more popular than money in the bank
I think at this point we need to
establish just let's get back to basic
save that money understand if you do get
that tax refund be very prudent with it
but do you guys the question though do
you guys think that they're just putting
a Band-Aid on this right now because I
mean how long we've been talking about
like this bubble that's gonna burst are
they just waiting to see for the next
Administration whoever it's going to be
well uh
I'll use Pat's uh metaphor we've been on
steroids in this economy for well over a
decade yeah okay very low interest rates
the stimulus checks at some point if you
just continue to do steroids you're
gonna die yeah or once you get off the
steroids adverse cancer yeah that too we
all know uh liver King who was here a
few months ago it when you get off the
steroids just like when you get off
heroin there's gonna be a really rough
patch that you're gonna have to deal
with and I think that's essentially
what's
on the uh come up for the economy at
some point but you know the sun will
come out tomorrow so we might have to go
through some shitty hard times in order
to feel our best so you know Tom you
said something here about what happened
with 20 billion dollars less IRS says
Americans are getting 20 billion dollars
Less in tax refunds than the prior year
the uh they issued 69 million refunds at
198.9 billion dollars which is 23
billion dollars lower than last year the
average refund check is 28.78 about 9
lower than last year at 3305 this is
because there was no extra tax credits
or pandemic related stimulus payments
delivered by the federal government in
2022 the decrease in refund size can be
concerning for millions of Americans who
depend
on the influx of money from Uncle Sam to
make major purchases save on for
retirement or payoff debt about 75
percent of adults who expect to receive
a tax refund this year believe the money
is about to their about is important to
their overall financial situation
according to recent bank rate surveys so
here's the thing when you make money you
can't tell the difference between a
thousand dollars here five thousand
dollars here two hundred dollars here
500 here 1800 but when you're barely
paying all your bills and you got your
you know kids and schools and car
payment and debt and all this stuff
combined this this 23 billion dollars
being less this directly directly
impacts low and middle income families
Tom yeah absolutely you know I saw a
chart a couple years ago that showed
that once a year usually in the month of
May and June that a credit card balances
would drop and and they were tied
directly to tax refunds everybody gets
your taxes in and they would get two
grand back or something that average
would you saw there and that was
actually down 500 bucks year over year
the numbers Pat just shared and so they
would drop that and then slowly over the
course of the Year 100 here 100 there it
would come back up remember we're
talking about Americans average American
making 47 to 52 000 and so they get
their refund back and then they slowly
start using the credit card up again
then the refund would come back and do
it and we we had this illusion that uh
Adam was just talking about that you had
this oh stimulus check remember those
stimulus checks were 1400 bucks so two
of those stimulus checks was like
getting an extra tax refund that year
and we saw that it dropped uh we saw it
it dropped a credit card balances a lot
and then they bounced back up thanks to
um poor discipline and inflation
inflation hit hard and right now the the
consumer is is stinging and we'll talk a
little bit later but it the the mar the
stock market oil prices are completely
different but right now consumers man
they gotta
they got to conserve and they're being
conserved at gunpoint and the gunpoint
is the is the inflation rate well you
know I love this chart this fear greed
index I'm constantly referencing it our
friend Malik over there was gracious
enough to pull it up thanks 30 days ago
30 days ago we did this okay and it was
almost extreme fear category 32 I think
32 days 30. it says a month ago 30. yeah
okay and now we're back in greed
territory and as Warren Buffett always
says be fearful when people are greedy
be greedy where people are fearful again
going back to your stim to getting your
tax refund uh be very fearful yeah they
did in Bitcoin just cracked 30 000. it
did Bitcoin cracked thirty thousand the
lower it hit was what fifteen sixteen
thousand rather than that yes right 15
16 000 it's at 30 now so uh uh Michael
Saylor apparently bought a bunch of much
more Bitcoin I think about three weeks
ago or five weeks ago he went on bitcoin
so it you know the the the concept the
the old principles of saving money right
now applies uh this is not the season to
be Reckless with your savings you know a
lot of people are
sitting there thinking well you know the
stocks are up Market's up it's doing
okay we're doing great this is not over
yet this this season of unpredictability
the other day a statistic I saw by
Charles Schwab that Charles Schwab's
depositors are decreasing if you type in
Charles Schwab depositors decree
decreasing uh uh deposits shrink there
you go this is from what New York Times
Charles Schwab's deposits go shrink but
profits grow faster than expected okay
as weird as it sounds this is one of the
names that was brought up by three
different uh investment bankers I spoke
to that one of the fears of a bank
they're worried about is Schwab now
don't get me wrong this is purely
speculation that names are being thrown
out this is one of them we may have
another bank or two or three Buffett
came out yesterday and he said something
interesting he said I'm willing to bet
anybody a million dollars is what he
said that no depositor will lose any
money that's what he said he says no
depositor will lose any money because
Warren Buffett will bet you million
dollars that no one in the U.S will lose
a penny of money to a bank failure this
year now depositor keyword what does he
say deposited he didn't say no bank will
lose money yeah he didn't say no
investor in the bank will lose money he
said no depositor right recently sent an
interview that there's no reason for
anyone to worry about the safety
security or availability of their
deposits on the U.S bank and he's
willing to bet his money on it in an
interview with CNBC Buffett said I will
gladly put a million dollars of my own
money in the bank and have anybody else
put a million dollars in and at the end
of the year if any American depositor
had lost money from a bank failure the
other fellow gets the name um
gets to name where the two million
dollar goes to to what charity Buffett
himself typically keeps his money in the
U.S treasury bills the vast amount of
money held by billionaire and his
investment from Berkshire Hathaway
exceeds the fdi's coverage limit of 250
000 which I believe they have 100 can
you find out how much of uh Berkshire
Hathaway has in cash right now I think
the number is between 75 to 125 billion
unless if they just bought something how
much does Berkshire Hathaway has in cash
right now 129 billion dollars is what
they had four months ago obviously this
is a March 10th story that's telling you
what they had at the end of the year but
they have around 100 billion dollars of
cash they're sitting in themselves so
you know there is the possibility that
something could happen to Banks does
that mean depositors are going to lose
their money no one knows here's a part
when you're talking inflation
um Goldman Sachs
has already said the SMP is going to be
flat in 2023 no growth no returns
Goldman Sachs themselves are going hard
into alternative assets non-duplicatable
assets alternative assets would art many
institutions have already maxed out 30
to 50 percent into alternative assets
one of the alternative assets is fine
art last year Prices rose on average 29
percent per Barons 29 2022 was the
biggest auction year ever highest total
from the three big auction houses nearly
18 billion dollars as crazy as the
season was auction houses did 18 billion
record-breaking last last year and last
time inflation was this High
Contemporary Art appreciated on an
average of 20 percent per year again the
last time inflation was this High
Contemporary Art appreciated at an
average of 20 so having said that this
is a sponsorship to Masterworks somebody
we've been uh doing work with now for I
think about a year I like what they
stand for there's a lot of people that
would like to have a piece of art that's
five million bucks 10 million bucks or a
million dollars a bank seat a Warhol but
you don't have the money to go buy
something like that or Picasso you can
now buy a share into any of these art
through Masterworks you do have to uh be
a member to have 660 000 members and uh
paintings have sold out in minutes so if
you want to be a part of this click on
the link below uh in the description Rob
if we can make sure to do that to go to
masterworks.art forward slash PVD
podcast once again masterworks.art
forward slash Peabody podcast I highly
recommend you look into this
everyone their pieces are qualified with
the SEC and broken into shares so it's
not like they're doing it without the
SEC it's all regulated industry the way
they're selling this so again
Masterworks dot art forward slash PVD
podcast or click on the link below so so
that's that part Tom going back to what
we're talking about here uh uh with the
economy okay going back to talking about
the economy here Amazon has been talking
about all the people they're laying off
right we're laying off newspapers
another eleven thousand another this
another debt here's another 9 000 people
they're getting ready to lay off amid a
layoff wave that has expanded past Tech
to include belt weathers now like dial
3M here's a full list of major U.S
companies making Cuts in 2023. uh Rob if
you can pull up the story as well so
people can see this Amazon has announced
it's cutting nine thousand rules on top
of the 18 000 job Cuts announced earlier
this year bringing a total to 27 000.
Amazon is a large group of major
corporations that have made significant
Cuts in 2023 meta and Google and find
Finance Behemoth Goldman Sachs the
layoffs have primarily affected the tech
sector which is now hemorrhaging
employees at a faster rate than any
other point during the pandemic
according to the data cited by Wall
Street Journal a site tracking the
layoffs since the start of the pandemic
tech companies have slashed more than
150 000 jobs in 2022 alone compared to
80 and 20 and 15 021 let me say that one
more time in 2022 was 150 thou and 2021
was fifteen thou and at the peak of the
pandemic was 80 thou okay so here's some
of the other companies that are laying
off their people Rob if you have this
Open Door 560 jobs McKinsey 1400 jobs
David Bridal
9236 jobs I didn't even know they had
that many employees virgin orbit 85
percent of staffers EA 78 780 employees
Amazon nine thousand Walmart about 200
employees Roku 200 staffers accentures
19 000 LinkedIn 2200 Series XM
475 meta 10 000 City Group hundreds of
jobs way Mo 209 jobs GM 500 salary jobs
Twitter 200 thoughtworks 500 Yahoo 20 of
their employees DocuSign 10 of their
employees GoDaddy eight percent of
workers Disney seven thousand jobs
affirm 19 of its Workforce Zoom 15 of
its staff return to office eBay 500 jobs
Pinterest 150 jobs Dell five percent of
the workforce rivian six percent of jobs
bdg media eight percent Intel 343 jobs
Splunk 325 jobs FedEx more than 10
percent of top managers PayPal seven
percent of total Workforce 2 000
employees IBM 4 000 jobs HubSpot 500
jobs Dow two thousand Global employees
sap up to three thousand employees 3M
2500 Spotify six percent of its
Workforce 600 employees Google 12 000
employees Vox seven percent of their
staff we work 300 employees is Capital
One 1100 Tech workers Wayfair thousand
employees Microsoft 10 000 workers
BlackRock three percent of their Global
Workforce or 500 employees crypto.com 20
of their staff Goldman Sachs six and a
half percent of global Workforce thirty
two hundred employees bny melon 1500
jobs I'm about to be done folks DirecTV
10 of management staff verily uh part of
alphabet 15 of a workers coinbase 950
workers Amazon eighteen thousand Vimeo
eleven percent of workers and last but
not least Salesforce 10 of its staff 7
000 jobs these are all the companies and
so quick question what like Amazon's
laying off all these people I mean
people are still using Amazon like like
crazy every like not what where are
these layoffs coming from you know who's
happy right now oh guess who's happy
right now shareholders because stocks
went up this is one way of making money
Tom once you take the lead from here
okay I'm gonna make this very simple
choir layoffs good I'll make it in one
very very simple thing you and your wife
have had a house which you have for 20
years your two children are now
graduating college and you're not
sending checks to college and those kids
are no longer home eating they're no
longer on your car insurance guess what
you've got extra money each month for
the first time in a long time that is
exactly on a massive scale what happens
when companies lay this off the market
loves it because they say you're if you
can keep your sales even flat to where
you are right now flat even if you stop
growing a little bit during a recession
it's flat but your costs are coming down
so you're gonna have more profit it pops
the stock price it moves the market
index right now if you were just putting
money into Cash funds with any any of
the reputable you know uh uh you know uh
organizations I'm not going to list them
so it sounds like we're favoring one or
the other but any of the reputable
brokerage firms that cater to Consumers
you just put in a cash fund or in a
market if you look long term like an S P
ETF because over the course of time the
s p has always beat the market on a on
an index basis but the market loves
these layoffs and they love what's going
on and I'll tell you how much they look
if you're going to decide what to wear
when you get up in the morning you look
at the temperature you look at the
weather report right Rob can you pull up
the vix and show this to America
you see here where's the vix right now
1753 the vix is a temperature gauge that
the market uses of volatility over 20
and it's stormy outside and you will go
and you'll you could correlate the vix
being up almost at 35 to banking issues
svb bank and stuff right now we've had a
spike and law the layoff announcements
you see they're in March Pat the vix has
dropped down to 1750 so solidly under
20. the market temperature says hey it's
not too volatile out here it's actually
a good time to to invest that's what the
market thinks and if I could add one
more thing
IPOs have been kind of quiet but IPOs
may be coming back this week SeatGeek
just now actually this week actually it
was yesterday I caught this yesterday as
well as um one of my favorite writers
over at uh one of my daily newsletters
caught this at the same time is SeatGeek
just filed an S1 which is basically a
letter they send the SEC say we're going
public and they went out at you know at
a billion dollar valuation and so in the
market the market is going to feel and
look different than the Consumer news
it's not out of sync what's happening
now is the layoffs are helping companies
stock prices and even in the recession
and the market is very open to
investment and you're going to see IPOs
this year
but when they lay off all those uh I
mean it's good for the market you're
saying but what about all the all the
employees that are still working there
they just have to work harder correct
like those people have Amazon's laying
off all these people that means somebody
has to pick up that slack right your job
has to be done well I think we had a
couple stories that were on this like
about uh people that were that were uh
investing in themselves 25 more training
that they were availing themselves to so
why are somebody back in the office
saying you know I'm gonna definitely
spend 25 more time on uh training why
they want to be valuable and they don't
want to be the next guy on that long
list that Pat just read gotcha I think I
think this uh you know classic case of
supply and demand over covid who had all
the leverage a lot of people would say
that the employees had the leverage
right I'm not coming into the office I'm
working via Zoom I'm working from
anywhere
um now at this point employers have the
leverage you know you're I know you're
in favor of typically cutting the bottom
10 of a Workforce anyway things change
so dramatically during covet so let me
just kind of let me just kind of give
you a better metaphor two years ago we
all remember that it was hot girl summer
yeah hey it's hot girl summer all right
girl do your thing last year our boy
Chad Hanks was on and was white boys
summer yeah okay this summer it is
tightened the F up don't get fired
summer remember your piano layoffs are
coming tighten up yeah remember I'm
sorry I just interrupted you Adam sorry
about that remember your man on the
street interview with the girl that had
come down for spring break oh your
stimulus check oh yeah oh yeah I said oh
did you get a stimulus check South Beach
she said how much did you get uh 1400
hell no I got 5600 like oh [__] she's
like I got dependents I go how much did
you spend on this trip to South Beach
5600.
let me say this still about a question
you asking the point Tom was making yeah
uh people working in the office spend 25
percent more time on Career Development
this is a Bloomberg story gotcha
according to data from wfh research uh
which is working from home people
working in the office spend 25 percent
more time on Career Development
activities than those working remotely
including mentoring formal training and
professional development you can't do
that at the house yeah the figures
support the argument for hybrid work
schedules as younger workers and
particular benefits from an in-person
mentorship on on-the-job training
research has shown that working in the
same building has an outsized effect on
workers training and that face-to-face
interactions with managers can be
advantageous for career development
employees who have more face-to-face
interactions with their managers are
promoted to a higher rate and this could
explain a third of the gender gap in
promotions at the large Financial firm
studies now the last sentence there was
a little bit of a politically correct
statement they added in there but that
should kind of tell you that if you're
in there you're being challenged you're
being pushed you're being seen you're
being held accountable you're being
driven you're being asked hey how come
you're not doing this have you thought
about things you may want to read this
did you see this article you're hearing
other people having conversations with
each other that's helping you grow
you're sitting home who are you
listening to yeah you're listening to
your you know little dog right there
barking at you hey can you walk me for
five minutes and come back all these
other distractions so in a season like
this as crazy the economy is this is the
season to recreate yourself most the
people at the top recreate themselves
very regularly and so the speed between
three different people let me kind of
explain this part so this will make
sense to you this has been my experience
having studied you know coming up as a
competitor as a regular guy that was a
21 year old army guy I'm like who am I I
watched all my peers
and I asked myself who's changing most
often so you got three people you meet
Johnny a year from now two years from
now three years from now four years from
now five years one is the same person
right okay no problem guess what life's
gonna be the same if it's hard it's
gonna be harder because you're getting
older so your market value is also going
lower right okay the middle one is maybe
recreate themselves once a year okay or
once every other year typically they
recreate themselves because of a crisis
they're forced to recreate themselves
they're forced to change they got fired
you know heartbreak something happens to
their Force I better change or else this
but these guys typically after they
recreate themselves and they see
immediate results they go back to their
shitty habits and then boom they're
forced again so every two to five years
they're forced to recreate themselves
the third group dude every three to six
months you don't see them you don't
recognize them they're talking about a
whole different thing their minds and a
whole different things they're working
developing on this working on this this
project that project this one so you're
like man I can catch up to this guy
anymore it's because they create
themselves more often the best
compliment you can get today from
somebody you haven't seen for the
longest time is man I don't recognize
you what happened to you you've changed
if everybody recognizes you all the time
and you're the same you end up creating
yourself this is
a season where many will be forced to
recreate but those who choose to
recreate and keep recreating yearly if
not even faster than that future looks
very bright for you those who sit around
blaming upset at the economy frustrated
to you know around the things that they
have zero control over I just hate to
say to you 2023 is going to be hard 2024
is going to be harder 2025 is going to
be harder and harder and life's going to
get harder and harder and harder and
harder and harder if you don't recreate
yourself I
just in the last
um
30 days how many grandmothers have died
in the building here
in the past 30 days three what in this
in this building here
how many buildings do how many people do
we have here we don't have thousands
we're 65 64 whatever the numbers yeah
okay so as you age first goes grandma
grandpa then goes Aunt Uncle then goes
parents then goes peers then goes
siblings then goes you
and you age you're more surgeries my
dad's at the hospital again today you
have more things you got to get checked
out you got to go do a lot of different
things life gets harder as you age the
worst thing you can do is knowing those
seasons are coming is by adding even
more hard things to it by not improving
and being proactive this is the worst
season to be reactive only the people
that are suffering consequences today
are those that have stayed in reactive
mode for the last 10 20 years all you've
been doing is reacting to the economy
reacting to a war reacting to inflation
reacting to gas prices reacting to the
economy reacting 229 reacting to Trump
reacting to Biden and a few people
around our Center saying man how when
are you going to stop just reacting and
being proactive when are you gonna stop
being freaking just reacting and you're
wondering why life is getting harder
dude my dad craziest thing Sunday we're
talking
and he's having a conversation I don't
know who he's talking to I think he's
talking to
um there was two people there he's
talking to and at your house my house he
says uh
I was 21 years old when I got out of the
army he says okay
put your shoes on we're going somewhere
where we going I'll tell you let's go so
we go to the Forest Lawn I said why are
we at the Forest Lawn he says we're
buying these six plots I said dad what
are you talking about you're 60 years
old he says we're buying these six plots
and he bought it for like sixteen
hundred dollars a plot at Forest Lawn by
the way they're each 15 000. ridiculous
yeah so Michael Michael Jackson is
buried up there so so he buys and he
says why he says we're gonna be ready
when the day comes you don't need to buy
my plot I bought my plot already for you
and you can be right next to me see the
man is all about anticipation proactive
preparation
these boring principles makes people's
lives around you better I love traveling
with Tom you know why say [__] hits the
fan on a flight that we're going so one
time it happened with Hawaii Thomas
already got seven plans he already knows
what Delta's got what this guy's got
with that you have no idea how safe I
feel traveling with this guy okay
because Tom is the epitome as being of
being proactive and prepared right being
around people that are reactive stress
level goes up anxiety goes up you're so
worried you have no idea what's gonna
happen dude people that give you peace
around you they're prepared proactive
people so today listen if you're
listening to this and you're kind of
stressing out because you're more on the
reactive side well then change let's
roll no more reactive by the way this
doesn't mean proactive people are not
reactive proactive people are
automatically reactive but reactive
people are not automatically proactive
be proactive and reactive instead of
just reactive and life's going to be
fine for you for many many years to come
so the the reactive folks are about to
pay a price hopefully they'll change the
proactive people trust me are going to
be fine that was awesome that was
fantastic and and talking about the
point of the grave and since you already
know where you know this train is going
to end at one point what do you have to
lose go for it do it don't don't be lazy
my mentality has changed recently
because of that that same fact we know
we're all going to die what are you
waiting for do it you just you bought
your plot a plot for fifteen thousand
dollars but you know what Beyond but not
because I'm lethargy always remember
lethargy
lethargy leather um it's very
interesting uh on Bismarck podcast on
Monday there's a guy that asked me he
says hey um should I sell my house and
use that to start my business should I
go rent with a friend and I sat there
thinking about that and the answer I
gave to him is if you're thinking about
doing that you know and and setting the
dollars aside he was he was making a
very informed choice about being
prepared that if he wanted to step out
and start a company and the things that
he thought that he knew a lot about the
industry and stuff he was willing to
sell his house right now with what he
can with the peak there's a little bit
of peak he's probably gonna make more
than it was worth in 2019-18
and then and then do it and there's
other people that talk to me and says
hey you know I've got about five
thousand dollars and I can put about 7
500 credit card that's 10.5 and I'm
thinking starting company doing this and
this I always tell those people don't do
that don't do that because there's so
much risk of starting a company don't do
that you you got to go in and be
prepared and I had this guy go well then
I'm gonna save the money but my lease is
coming up and I'm living by myself I
have a buddy I think I'm going to share
a smaller townhouse with them because
it's going to lower my monthly and I'll
just start saving because I think I
could stay ready for this I've added it
up I could save about 20 grand over two
years and maybe I'll start the business
with that and I'm like Bingo you know or
maybe don't start the business and he's
got 20 000 saved now he's got the
discipline of saving so the preparation
that we're talking about you can be
preparing now you can look around at
your expenses right now and you can make
decisions right now about about
preparation you know there's a city that
you can be a millionaire and be broke
guess what that city is New York City
let's go baby let me tell you
wealthiest city on the planet with 340
000 millionaires has the highest
concentration of Resident millionaires
at 340 Tokyo San Francisco Bay Area
followed in second and third place
respectively London dropped to fourth
place on the list with 258 and followed
by Singapore to 240 000 the report
focused on people with netwards of
million dollars or more the ultra
wealthy uh lost uh 10 trillion dollars
um or 10 from their net worth of 2022
driven by global economic uncertainty
the energy crisis and the war in Ukraine
New York is also the home of the most
centi millionaires 100 million plus
while San Francisco Bay area is home to
the most billionaires globally China's
Hank Zoo uh Hangzhou uh topped the list
of the fastest growing cities when it
comes to resident millionaires over the
past decade with millionaire growth of
105 so um
if in New York City Rob if he can pull
it up let's pick a city okay let's pick
a city go to realtor.com okay go to
realtor.com and let's do
um New York City just type in New York
City okay and uh uh yeah New York City
and go up and properly are you on rent
or you're on buy click on rent all the
way at the top go on rent yeah so New
York City search that let's see what
rent is like in New York City all right
zoom in right there let's see what that
looks like three to seven thousand
thirty six hundred for a 427 square foot
place a studio by the way this is 427.
nuts this is like 427 square feet so
this in New York is 3 700 the second one
you're paying 4 800 for a 494 square
foot uh space okay keep going lower
let's just see what okay 63rd Street is
right up with Central Park Central Park
starts at 59th dude so let's look at the
cheap one right there that one is what
2600 you have to live in the kitchen
though you see that you have to live in
the kitchen keep going down keep going
down with rent to see what it looks like
five thousand three thousand starters 38
38.95 for 375 foot
square foot Place 42 see that building
to the left that looks like a a uh that
looks like a lot of different things but
that's a commentary in Cleveland yeah
built 352 square foot Place guys this is
352 square feet let me say this one more
time this room is 352 square feet so
you're in the studio room this could be
400 square feet you would pay 4 200 for
this in New York City no so you have to
be a millionaire in New York City to
barely budge make it make your studio if
you're not you got to live like a an
hour out 30 minutes out and that's
including the traffic have roommates in
that little room like hey guys if you
got that corner you've got this point at
this corner here we go I know people
that literally do that or you build a
fake wall well it's a thousand bucks
between two bedrooms I've seen it all oh
wild with you I love New York City I
already have roommates yeah I'm listen
I'm from Yonkers New York I'm not I'm
happy in Florida I'm about to go to but
listen here's what I like you know what
I love about New York there's something
about the Yankees right there's
something about you know when I think
about baseball cards I think about New
York Yankees Mickey Mantle I think about
steinburner that's an owner to me when I
think about owners I think two names him
and Jerry bus those are the guys that
just just set the tone with what they
did right uh the city the fight the dog
fight the culture that whole thing yeah
you would look forward to going I'm
about to go to New York in a couple
weeks by the way you know the top
restaurant there 11 Madison right the
the guy unreasonable Hospitality that is
they're they're doing 18 million year
One Restaurant okay turning into the
number one restaurant in the world three
Michelin star there's so many things you
can sell about this place here's the
crazy part you realize if New York City
got a governor
that ran for eight years and he cleaned
house with taxes he cleaned the streets
and made it safer he made it great for
startups to go there he actually
invested into police and encouraged the
mayor students invest in police and he
cleaned the place up you realize good
luck everybody else yeah that's how
great of a place that place is but
unfortunately nobody is saying anything
about the people of New York the fight
of New York the DNA of New York anytime
I got a sales guy recruited in L.A in
Texas anywhere that was from New York I
preferred it because you can challenge
him you can push him you can kick his
ass he didn't give a [__] matter of fact
he did better the more you did that with
him there's a certain energy about
people from New York they negotiate in a
more straight up way they're just kind
of like hey here's how we do this no
problem it saves a lot of time versus
well let me tell you it's a very easy
way to do business but unfortunately you
know what they're doing right now it's
not it's not not slowing down at FYI
this whole concept with Florida that
they're saying wow you know people are
not going to be moving to Florida
anymore page 13 New York Exodus to
pro-business Florida is a hot Trend that
won't simmer down anytime soon okay this
is a fox business story thousands of
Americans have moved from New York to
Florida during the pandemic to escape
high taxes and crime rates the trend has
continued with 10 000 New Yorkers
already leaving the state in the first
quarter of 2023. this year folks not
last year okay and this is written by
Jenna an associate at Sotheby's
International Realty Florida's Chief
Financial Officer Jimmy Petronas said
that 900 new residents move to the state
every day from the state such as New
York jersey and Illinois 900 a day
that's 27 000 a month Florida is proving
attractive to home buyers because of its
lower taxes and pro-business environment
democrat-led States including California
Illinois New York saw the biggest
decline in population while being at
home to some of the highest tax burdens
in the U.S
yeah I mean the Secret's out I I I've
been experiencing this for two decades
now about New Yorkers coming down for
New Year's coming down for vacation
coming down to have a great weekend here
and I would always ask them I'm like
what would it take for you to move to
Florida like ah no the Florida's like
you know vacation come in the winter
this ain't for me I don't know it's a
and now we're starting to see they're
like no no I'm here I'm here real good
now Secrets out whether that's because
of covid and all the lockdowns because
of that because of the low taxes
business friendly DeSantis mayor Suarez
down in Miami he's been a major element
of this and here's what I always tell
New Yorkers kind of like what Pat was
saying about their grit their grind
their hustle their stick to itness it's
like if you keep that attitude that you
that led you to have success in New York
in freaking Miami with a running a Cuban
time and they just like everything's
going like you're gonna run circles
around the people here and they're doing
it so yeah you'll own the city I mean
listen the DNA doesn't leave you the DNA
of a fighter that goes to any place like
I remember one time I came to Florida
and I was speaking at this uh Deerfield
office and they said well Patrick you
can all you have to sales people showed
up to the meeting late I said guys what
the hell was this all about
and they said oh Patrick We're on floor
at a time I said I don't give a [__]
what time you're on okay if you ain't on
time close the door and get out no no
that's not how it's ran in Florida if
I'm running this meeting get out so like
are you serious I said yes I said come
here with me open up the uh what do you
call it the um not the blinds the glass
the drape whatever the drapes is on the
window yeah and I opened it up I said
look outside the window I said how many
buildings you see out there
I said count them they're like you
seriously want us account I said you get
the point how many buildings you see out
there hundreds okay who built those
buildings did somebody build those
buildings that came in late at 11
o'clock
how how much work did it take to build
those assets so don't give me the [__]
about there's floor at a time no those
buildings were built by Killers and
somebody paid millions of dollars to buy
those buildings killers are in every
city it's just you guys are not The
Killers right now and you're lazy and
you're tired and you're buying this
excuse you take a killer from LA to New
York to Iowa to Boise to Wyoming even to
Chas Washington outside of Portland that
no longer exists they're going to whoop
some ass and Lead leaders lead
everywhere they go so the New York DNA
Florida saying come on down here wasn't
the sentence given five thousand dollar
bonuses for cops to come down here yeah
yep she was giving them out right yeah
they were coming good for you of course
and this is not going to slow down by
the way Tom any thoughts on this I I
think
I got like five thoughts on it and then
the first is I I think what you're
seeing in here I mean good grief
unemployment two and a half percent you
know in the two and a half or two point
six percent pick a city in Florida major
ones Jacksonville Orlando Jacksonville
is actually the biggest city in Florida
by the way not Miami uh support that's
the Port City they had a Super Bowl
there they got an NFL team there there's
a lot going on up there and you take a
look we got 2.5 unemployment and you put
a playing field in place you put a
canvas in place like you know the
leaders in Florida and there's a lot of
credits given to DeSantis well deserved
but you know what there's also what
mayor Suarez is doing when leaders put a
canvas in in place that attracts people
they come and paint beautiful pictures
and that's what you're seeing here
people are coming down here and you know
what I like it that you know why Florida
is going to be safer because I like a
few New York cops down here I want New
York cops to be on the police force down
here I want them to be happy and then I
want their attitude I want their their
focus I don't want them to be laid back
I love what's Happening Here we had a
guy that just when I came here we had a
guy just gave a Super Chat the
cryptotainer I'm from New York sister
with fam uh and my mom moved to Florida
last year pbd gave me a job I moved to
Florida this summer got banking sales
real estate and crypto experience send
your resume to info at valuetainment.com
once again send your resume to info
about attainment.com we're always
looking we have right now I don't know
how many job openings we got right now
but we're hiring left and we just
brought an editor-in-chief that'll start
I think a week from today or two weeks
from today uh former anyways you'll see
the people were bringing left and right
right now when we're hiring we're
looking for strong Talent if you're one
of them send us your resume
business analysts when I work at the biz
doc
send it in yep and more by the way and
more okay so the question about Dominion
when are we going to get to it we're
going to get to in the second half when
this thing is packed so once this thing
hits 8 000 we'll hit the Dominion story
because it is a story a lot of people
want us to talk about okay so uh Elon
Musk says he wants a normal person for
president in 2024 whose values are
smacking the middle of the country
um okay I mean a lot of people you know
the saying goes we need another Ronald
Reagan we need somebody that's a normal
person we need a young person we need
this we need that
and a lot of people are there but in an
interview with Fox he said he prefer a
normal person for president 2024 someone
with common sense and uh whose values
are smack in the middle of the country
adding that they would be great musk who
voted for Joe Biden in 2020 election has
praised and criticized both Donald Trump
and Biden in recent years calling for
maximum age limit for lawmakers and same
politicians should be ideally within 10
or at least 20 years of the average of
the population musk's political stances
have shifted to the right in recent
years and last summer he said he voted
Republican for the first time backing
former Texas GOP representative Myra
Flores in a special election here's a
guy
that voted for Biden
who's saying something like this okay
he's a guy that voted for Biden the same
we need somebody like this what do you
think about his comments here Adam I
think he's spot on I think it's you know
whether it's uh Elon Musk whether it's a
Joe Rogan whether it's a Bill Maher
in terms of political ideology economy
in that camp where it's like you're
typically just more of a classic liberal
and you're like here's what I kind of
stand for and this is kind of what I
believe I'm not I don't have any strong
ideologies super far left or super far
right but I think as we've seen over the
last few years I think a lot weather was
none of those guys were voting for Trump
zero Elon Musk was not voting for Trump
Bill Maher certainly wasn't Rogan was
definitely not and I think you know just
putting myself in that type of Camp I
was not I think all of them including
myself are like
kind of looking at this Trump character
now I don't know it's sleepy Joe just
ain't it yeah you know I think that's
why people are so attracted to santis
it's kind of like Trump light uh but I
think at this point uh everyone well any
plastic I've not been doing well lately
that's true that's true but like other
than Coors Light is maximizing Bud Light
drama and it is I think it's it's if
you're if you're one of those people uh
what I would say 10 of the country who
has an open mind
okay we already know that 45 is going
right 45 going left there's nothing that
you're going to do to sway these
people's opinions they are dug in oh
yeah nothing so those 10 those people
who have voted for Bush voted for Obama
voted for Trump voted for Biden they're
swing voters I think they are the people
that we need to uh continue to pay
attention by the way the other day we
had clay Travis and Buck Sexton here
okay and good guys we were having a
great conversation with them they were
more they're more on the DeSantis Camp
they want the scientists to uh uh uh
become the president which more power to
them to send to say strong leader great
guy that's the reason why we're in
Florida if you really think about it the
reason why all of us are in Florida is
because of Ron DeSantis okay well me
mostly because my parents had sex here
at 40 years no you were in Dallas and
Addison and then you ended up moving
from Addison back to Florida because we
moved to Florida so you were out what
I'm saying is okay we moved back because
I we said we're moving there because the
policies because we're going to go to
Greenwich and then Iran brought us back
here
and one of the questions I asked him is
the following question I want you to
think about this year and I want to hear
what you're going to say
they asked I asked them the question you
can't you and I cannot answer because we
know what they said okay they don't know
it okay I said what do you think
is the amount of influence broken and
I'm going to go to you first and I'm
going to go to you and I want you guys
to write the number down before you say
it okay what do you think is the
influence Rogan and musk have in
flipping vote so
just two three four years ago
Joe Rogan endorsed Bernie Sanders yeah
okay whatever the timeline was Elon Musk
voted for Joe Biden just three years ago
now both of them are saying to save the
country you have to vote Republican and
not even that Joe went as far as saying
I would vote for Trump okay I would vote
for Trump let me read the story and then
you guys can give me your number and
folks if you're listening to this I want
you to put your answer as well some of
you guys watch the podcast so you know
what they said but I want to hear your
answer
um
I would vote for Joe I would vote for
Donald Trump Joe Rogan opposes Joe
Biden's cabin around the world's the
most powerful country I would vote for
Trump before I would vote for Biden the
thing with Biden is he's gone you know
he's gone you're going to be relying on
his cabinet and I knew his cabinet would
be a sideshow of diversity you can't
have those kinds of people running a Ben
and Jerry's you sir certainly can't have
those kinds of people running in heaven
the weapon most powerful country in the
world has ever known it's nuts said Joe
Rogan on his podcast okay so now show
the number one podcast in the world Elon
Musk runs Twitter richest man in America
most powerful guy in America the way he
is doing what he's doing with social
media and Technology
if they say vote Republican with elon's
140 million followers Joe Rogan's
podcast how many votes can they flip
how many votes can they flip out of
actual influence out of how many so all
you have to do is you have to say you
know a hundred thousand of their votes
that they would follow their lead to go
a uh you know a Libertarian like Joe uh
Joe Jorgensen or a Democrat to announce
saying I'm gonna vote for Trump because
Joe Rogan said vote for Trump because
Elon Musk said a vote for Trump if these
guys smarter than me are saying
something like this I should consider it
how many things will flip I'm gonna go
to you first I mean I think like
percentage-wise no number number because
because remember Trump lost 75 to 81
million
okay Trump lost 75 to 81 am I saying it
correctly 71 75 to 81 million yeah so
how many that will flip just because of
Joe Rogan and Elon Musk wow
foreign
15 10 to 15 million
what is that bad I had two people going
you know what Joe Rogan's telling let me
see what time thinks it's a lot
you asked you asked the number of votes
last and what I had done is of the 12
Indies I think Rogan can move
two of those percentage points and I
think Elon can move four that's that's a
big number so I'm saying
no no I'm saying if you give each of
them two and two of the 12 Indies in the
middle I think Rogan and Elon if they're
on the same side they'd move two each I
think you could move forward so how many
million go to 2020 total independent
voters
total independent voters in 2020
election you just take the total voters
and do 40 43 and 43 and everybody else
total election so how many people voted
it was like 156 yeah is that correct
150 75 and 81. so 75 and 81 is is uh
yeah 150
156. so the the middle was probably 20
million right there in the middle 15 and
half of 15 is seven so yeah
you're talking about Rogan and Elon
going hey guys listen do not vote
Democrat 100 they're going to be going
aggressively
at once they go over and over and over
they are super concerned about what's
going to be happening these guys will be
pushing this you know a a I'm I wouldn't
be surprised if DeSantis is on Rogan's
podcast in the next three to six months
I wouldn't be surprised if possibly
Trump meets with musk and they have a
meeting and I wouldn't be surprised if
some of those think those things happen
after they know who's on the right so if
it's the Santa's the sentence has got to
be on Rogan's podcast if they haven't
already had the conversation that is a
must but here's the point Tom two to
four percent
think about that number two to four
percent okay that's a real number it's
not 15 million two to four percent ends
up becoming what 10 15 million so you're
saying really the two to four percent
of the 12 is what you're saying so now
two to four percent of the 54 points of
those 14 points two to four points of
those 14 points correct so two to four
points of the let's just use the number
three okay three of fourteen
uh uh uh so let's let's let's do 156.
what's 156 times 14 14 well every every
one percent is 1.56 so so what is that
times 14.
that's what I'm saying so if we do 21
22. five six times
21 is what you're doing yeah like 21
people that are honestly in the middle
and that's your swing that we've all
know about which is 14 or 13 percent
right around there okay let's just say
13 yeah so that's 20 million okay 20
million you got 2 is 4 million that's
not enough
but three percent it's game over
okay you know what clay Travis and Buck
Sexton said he said only a hundred
thousand no he said one million no no
they said a hundred thousand can you rob
do you remember if it was a hundred
thousand or one million I don't remember
can you while we're doing this is there
a way you can find to see what they said
well see if you can I remember them
saying a hundred thousand let me give
you a little different perspective
the uh
the what do they call the general
population or when you win the um
general election when you win the uh
population what is it what is it called
not when you win the electoral college
when you win you'll vote popular vote
there you go that's the word I'm looking
for yeah that to me is irrelevant it's
irrelevant because
you're not going to swing 5 million
voters or 10 million voters even 2
million voters you need to swing a
hundred thousand voters in Wisconsin
finally 11 000 votes in Georgia we all
know what happened there okay find me 20
000 votes in Wisconsin find me ten
thousand votes in Pennsylvania
did they say that okay so that's
essentially what it comes down to
whatever the swing states are we all
know that it's 51.49 it's
50.6 to 49.4 it's so close it's so razor
thin that you don't need to swing
Millions either side by the way you need
there's a you need these swing States
these swing cities these districts that
can go either way that's who you need to
flip and by the way we saw in Florida
and the gubernatorial election what
happens when the independence break 72
percent
the independence broke 72 for DeSantis
and you go take a look at the map
everything was read except Broward and
the small County on the south side of
Orlando correct correct and it's the
same thing that happened in 2016 the
those same Independence broke for Trump
because Hillary wasn't campaigning in
the blue States or in the blue wall and
the same thing happened in 2020 when all
those same voters broke for Biden so the
independence of where it's at we all
know that preaching to the choir and
losing Independence the independent the
true Independence
follow what Rogan and musk have to say
the true Independence follower the
Libertarians and The Independents follow
what Rogan and musk have to say fully
agree with that so solely agree so to me
when clay Travis and buck sex and said a
hundred thousand I'm like
yeah I don't know I think it's a bigger
number than that Tom if it's three
percent I don't think it's three percent
but I don't think it's a hundred
thousand but if those two
go and they supported the way they do
I I don't know I mean they could change
the time oh my God here's what I was
considering you wonder what I was
considering there what I was considering
was I remember what happened with Rush
Limbaugh and Newt Gingrich I remember
what happened and remember remember that
that wave that came up and and bit and
bit Clinton really hard that was that
was like Rush demonstrating the power
you know of the medium of the time now I
look at it and I see what happened with
the Tea Party and so Pat it takes a few
voices but if the voices are a wave it's
not just Rogan it's Rogan's influence
base and it's the people that are in
that influence base that are influencing
others as well because right
yeah see I doubt the GOP would have won
the house in 94 without Rush Limbaugh
and that was what was Gingrich what he
called that contract with America was
that what it's called I think it was his
new thing anyway regardless of what it
was called the point was there was a
spark that pushed this thing over fast
and the same thing happened with tea
party so when things get tough and
there's a real Stark Choice America
voters can be moved what a point you
just made listen to this without rush I
doubt if we would have won the control
of his house in 1994 because he
clarified the issues Gingrich explained
he gave our candidates arguments to run
on he created a huge number of people
his impact was more than the 20 million
listeners a week it was all the people
they would go talk to wow my guess is
that the ripple effect of Rush was more
than 80 to 90 exactly that's exactly
what I'm saying with Rogan and musk
that's exactly what I think this is
going to be bigger I think this is going
to be if if Trump or the sentence can
win those two guys which descent is
they've both won over I mean he's won
both of them over you know both of them
their team the sentence is where they
are obviously musk doesn't want somebody
older than 70 his number was 69 even
younger than that so so
69 is more because anything to be less
than 70 anyways okay so we'll see I
think it's going to be a bigger number I
think I fully see that part where you're
training the trainers to go out there
and talk like we're having a meeting in
two weeks in Dallas 25 3 000 people are
going to show up it's called train the
trainers that meaning when they leave it
turns into 50 to 100 000 insurance
policies we didn't sell any policies
that way we trained the trainers to go
and find them now we have 350 nearly 400
000 policies we've written in the last
yeah 13 years right so that is the
effect of what they leave and what they
do okay yeah this is really fast but
it's kind of weird that you we wouldn't
need those people in the middle need uh
that influence from uh musk or Rogan
when can't you can't they just open
their eyes and see what's happening in
like how horrible this Administration
did but but think about how how much
people go and say I need a Oprah Winfrey
endorsement but actually think about how
Oprah Winfrey endorsed fetterman yeah
here's how she endorsed them she says
look I know Oz is somebody that's worked
with me for many years and I know
everybody's expecting me to support us
but I'm supporting fetterman I think
he's a good guy I think he's this versus
the difference between the way she
endorses and rush or Elan or Rogan
endorses says the following listen I
have a heart look at Rogue what did
Rogan say Rogan said what how did Rogan
explain why he would vote for uh uh
Trump said she's in the cabinet he said
he said I would vote for this because
you're gonna be relying on his cabinet
and I know his cabinet would be a
sideshow of diversity you can't have
those kinds of people running a Ben and
Jerry's you certainly can have those
kinds of people running a country the
most powerful country in the world so
that is an issue he's given to say it
was so much about diversity that you
didn't pick the best leaders for the job
right so the average person listens to
it and says that can't that's kind of
right he just shows diversity you can
have that so the way Oprah does it is
yes I support it's great versus the way
these guys are going to do this it's
going to be issue driven if it's issue
driven
80 to 90 million anyways let's go to
Dominion you guys ready let's go let's
talk Dominion okay
Fox to pay 787 million dollars
to settle election suit Dominion says
this is a Bloomberg story Fox News has
agreed to pay 787 million dollars to
settle Dominion voting system defamation
lawsuit when alleged that the network
aired bogus claims that Dominion rigged
the 2020 election against Donald Trump
evidence uncovered in the case showed
that fox knows Executives and top hosts
like Tucker Carlson privately derived
The Conspiracy Theory as Looney even as
they promoted it the settlement ends the
possibility of a trial in which Rupert
Murdoch the chairman of fox Corp and his
son would have to testify about the
oversight of the Network's new
representation presentations the
settlement allows Fox News to avoid
having to flatly apologize which means
neither Tucker and the other folks won't
have to apologize uh foxman sucker
Carlson Sean Hannity won't have to
apologize on air about the Dominion the
host will avoid being grilled on the
witness stand and won't have to issue
restrictions or make any other
statements on TV even on the network
acknowledged Foster statements were
broadcasted
the falsehood claims that Dominion made
by then Trump lawyer Giuliani and Sydney
Powell who appeared as guests on several
Fox shows pushed a false conspiracy
theory about Dominion flipping votes
from Donald Trump and Joe Biden by the
way this is a very very big news okay so
here's here's the problem with things
like this I'll give you my feedback and
then we can process it together
my my problem with something like this
is
um one
I love the fact that there is a form of
accountability okay the slippery slope
is
anytime a lawyer has a case that becomes
a precedent and that's the standard well
then guess what everybody else is
getting a phone call when these guys
indicted Trump what they don't realize
they did
for the next 300 years if there's still
a country here Republicans will always
be able to say the first president that
was indicted
was by the Democrats so if a future
Democrat tries to say this is not a good
look for the country we look divided to
the enemy hey Democrats you started it
and the forever forever they're going to
be able to say that you impeach the guy
two times and nothing happened just
because Nancy Pelosi celebrated that the
fact that they impeached them just to
humiliate them is what they did okay now
they may say well what do you mean human
humiliated us for calling us fake news
he wasn't wrong you were fake news you
said Russia whatever hey is there a
lawsuit with Russia for you so this may
cause Trump to go Sue CNN with Russia on
MSNBC and then his lawyers may say well
look if you did Dominion you did this to
my career you cost me this much money
well my business is my numbers happened
this that there's uh there's a lot of
things that this if I'm if I'm if this
is happening right now with Fox guess
who's worried
CNN is sitting there saying oh NBC is
sitting there ABC is sitting there
Morning Joe is sitting there all of
these guys are sitting there as much as
they're so happy because this is such an
in your face you know this is kind of
like you know how a sports team
dominates everybody in a league and they
hate them and then finally something
comes out deflategate I told you I knew
New England Patriots couldn't win and
the New England Patriots comes back and
wins again and again I told you the
Astros cheated and let you know and then
they come back and they win without it I
told you this so there's an element of
that that's happening today where
everybody on the mainstream media is
celebrating this having drinks getting
camera this is the biggest party they're
having to celebrate this but I think
there's going to be more things that's
going to backfire with this Tom I'll
tell you who I don't I I actually
believe that MSNBC and NBC and Brian
Roberts at Comcast have been remarkably
quiet on certain parts of this I think
they're concerned and I'll tell you why
if you go take a look at the steel
dossier and what Rachel Maddow did on
MSNBC
it's exactly what you said I would be on
Trump's side lining up at her door
because the steel dossier and everything
turns out
also fake also was wrong and so duck and
I think MSNBC
probably doesn't like this precedent
because of the way that they played uh
Russia in the steel dossier
to pick one just one yeah well I'll I'll
give you my little two cents right here
well obviously this is the number one
story across every single cable news
Outlet except for one yeah take a wild
guess who's not really covering this
story CNN no Fox how about that guy yeah
uh well as it turns out you know we can
go down the list of CNN and MSNBC fake
news uh Russia Scandal Ukraine
impeachment the list is too long turns
out it takes two to tango and it turns
out Fox News
is peddling fake news stories as well or
else they wouldn't settle for
billion dollars
million dollars still alive the lawsuit
was 1. I think 6 billion they set up for
a half 787 uh Million by the way guess
how much cash they have on hand Fox News
how much ticket so we just established
that what Berkshire Hathaway has a
hundred billion yeah 2.1 billion my
numbers Show 4 billion okay there you go
okay so what I'm saying is yes what I'm
saying is they've had to give up 20 of
their cash on hand that's a lot this is
no joke guys Fox News uh this is not a
good look for Fox News uh the the
biggest question is how will this affect
2024. Fox just paid the price for this
they avoided Tucker and Laura Ingram and
Sean Hannity and all the cohorts having
to basically be
show ponies for uh in a in a trial so
that they avoided literally getting egg
on their face they didn't have to
apologize they didn't have to admit
guilt they didn't have to you know give
accountability they just had to pay 787
million dollars I apologize for saying B
earlier but this is not a good look for
Fox News but uh this will go back to
three things again the same things that
the Democrats
I won't say one while they didn't lose
the midterms the same three things uh
election denial is not a winning message
news flash to Donald Trump stop it it
cost you in the midterms it just cost
Fox News you know three quarters of a
billion dollars yeah this is not a
winning message drop it when on your
merits win on your policies went on the
[__] show that is Joe Biden win on that
stop being a victim and say the truth
and win on that again because saying
that I really want it and it's all fake
news Well it's not a winning message
clearly I mean it just sucks for him
because and that sucks for him but I
mean can you blame somebody like Trump
not trusting the same people that did
all these investigations and all this
but in Dominion with the difference
Pat brought this up with Rudy Johny uh
Rudy Giuliani on the podcast the other
day it's like okay so let's say you
can't trust the system let's say you
can't trust the voting machines let's
say you can't trust government what
happens we saw what happened in Georgia
you encourage people to do what not vote
okay and that's why Georgia picks up two
Senate seats and you end up flipping the
Senate because you're encouraging your
base not to come out and vote because
you can't trust the machine this is a
losing message this is something we
never got behind of I mean we we listen
we interview everybody I don't care who
you are Olivia I'd love to have a Robert
reikon he won't show up we'd love to
have Bernie Sanders on I'm telling you
they won't show up of course not we
we've had all the guys that people you
have no you would never have Gen Con we
had them on you'd never have David
Panama you'd never have calculus you'd
never have Sam Cedar on and then you
know by the way you know on Twitter they
no longer say you would never have
because we have yep you would never have
this dude we don't mind sitting down
having a conversation
about this we even had Dinesh de souzon
I think at one point dude we did have
dinner yeah yeah so you know but but to
me to me uh this this is this is
concerning
um
in in a in a different way it's not it's
not at all a way of like uh what people
are thinking you know this is a
completely different way I think when
Alex Jones was sued for however much
money the money was billions yeah I'd
say that's a that's a that's a very
because what it what it makes people do
I mean if you if you if you think about
this fine
dude for how many years did CNN MSNBC
talk about Russia how many years was it
they still talk about a day for three
years they talked about it yeah how come
they're not sued over it that's a great
question why are they not being sued
over that hoax that they held they
should be if I'm if I'm Trump if I'm
Trump right now I'm calling my lawyers
and I'm saying you know what no problem
file a four billion dollar defamation
lawsuit against CNN MSNBC ABC CBS for
the Russian hoax with the Durham report
coming out sue them for four billion
dollars five billion dollars he may even
do 10 billion dollars because of those
every freaking day they did for how long
right but I don't think that's the
direction we should go to but I think
we're going this too late I think I'm
telling you right now if Trump is who I
think he is and the types of people he
has around him
why wouldn't he Sue those guys as a
defamation he's a counter puncher isn't
he's a New York counter puncher this is
like an this is a layup counter puncher
to Russia that needs to get done already
because you you know he can say he heard
the re-election they did there's so many
different ways they heard his company
his name his family the whole thing but
like but and Pat blind you though I'm
not listen we know that there's cheating
and voting I don't care what anybody
says I don't know about how Grand the
scale is but there's always there was
always discrepancies two things I want
to ask are they still going to use the
Dominion is Dominion still being used
for for the next coming elections like
do they it's Dominion across the board
is that being used all the time I
believe so and there's also something to
just keep tabs of there's another
lawsuit coming down the pike from the
other vote counting machine which is
called smartmatic yeah you familiar with
these guys yeah uh Dominion was suing
for what 1.3 billion smartmatic is suing
Dominion was soon for 2.7 billion okay
no smartmatic for 2.7 billion Dominion
was I think 1.6 and they got half of it
yeah something like that one point yeah
there's so many billions being flown
around with his domain name there's
gonna be settled right there so Fox
might end up having to pay another
billion dollars for endorsing these lies
so
but but I heard a lot of it was them
bringing on people who were saying
discrepancies especially do anything
computer I don't care what anybody says
I'm not saying they did but can you
really trust it the Integrity of just
voting and mail-in ballots and all that
all that it's just well I don't know
dude there's a difference we learned
from film mud CIA who was here he says
there's a big difference between what
you think and what you can prove 100 and
with much respect to Rudy Giuliani
because we had a great time with him I
thought he was people thought was he
nuts was he insane I was actually no no
it was impressed it's actually cool but
he firmly firmly firmly thinks yeah that
the election was stolen but he hasn't
done anything to prove it whatsoever I
remember vividly pbd asking me this
would have been in November of 2020 when
I'd never heard of Sydney Powell he's
like what do you think about this lady
and I'm like
I don't she's she's this is when she was
like Hugo Chavez came back from the dead
China like she's saying all these wild
over-the-top claims it's like holy [__]
she seems credible she seems like she
has it going on she says what do you
think I'm like I don't know I just I I I
this is see this is very odd it turns
out she ended up being a q Anon
conspiracy theory liar yeah uh but
it again a difference between what you
think and what you can prove a lot of
people genuinely think that the election
was stolen yeah I get it yeah but you
haven't proven anything but wait a
minute those are two different things a
person what this can't do a person
should have the right to think and
speculate
the problem with this is no this is you
know well you know you have to go prove
it is what you need to do yes a lot of
people that are speculating saying the
videos of people doing this the voting
the the lady pulling this and doing it
that stuff no one said a lot of that
stuff hasn't been proven wrong yeah it
just hasn't been like you know talked
about those are two different issues
that you got to isolate the the
isolating here is they kept driving this
over and over yeah okay cool I mean it
is what it is you chose to settle
by the way I've been part of lawsuits
and sometimes you're like no I'm not
going to sell I'm going to go with it
great it could take four or five years
and then you may pay more or you may
just say you know what I'll just settle
right now pay half a million dollars or
200 000 or a million dollars and move on
what they're doing here is they're not
saying they're just saying let's settle
let's move on let's put this behind us
you know we probably don't have a chance
of winning this there there's a
conversation that happens with the
lawyer they sit there and you say listen
what are the chances we can win
something like this uh 20 but it could
cost us this this this this that okay if
we set up how much could we pay for
right now if we win it's going to be
this but if we lose they could get us
for the whole thing if we settle right
now can you start talking about settling
yes and then they go start having the
discussion yeah no this does not mean
there was no possibility of any photo
voter fraud this just means the Dominion
came in they fought to protect their
name and their reputation yeah the part
where I would like to see take place
which is deeply concerning it's not
needing 45 days to count for 30 based
account however many days it was to
count I want to get the results the same
night yup so when you all of a sudden
say oh people stop working listen
everybody gets skeptical with that what
do you mean you stop working there's one
event that happens every four years you
don't stop working on those days you
know when people don't sleep and you
have a lot of tired people at work when
there's World Cup you know why
especially when it's another country and
the game is at 2 A.M and you're waking
up to watch the freaking game yeah that
happens once every four years it's
called the World Cup you don't say you
know what we're going to delay this
thing yeah because and then we're tired
no no it's an election sit your ass down
count the votes if you don't want to do
the job don't be part of accounting the
votes and let somebody else do it that
they take this thing valuable but that
that's the area where we sit there and
say I'm sorry that's a little weird
so for the people that are
skeptical about those types of things I
I I'm fully supportive of that because
we should sit there on Election night
and go to sleep knowing who our
president is for the next four years we
shouldn't go to sleep I'm saying we're
going to need 35 more days to count my
six-year-old knows how to count up to
pretty high number if they're looking
for people to count I can send four
people my kids yeah even Brooklyn is
learning how to count she's 23 months
old okay so if they need help we got
some support here for them yeah I'll say
one thing I fully agree with you one
thousand percent and there is a
difference between
being skeptical and questioning and
being certain and to anybody whether
it's Donald Trump definitely colluded
with Russia 100 it's like oh you know
that Bob yeah who watches CNN for two
hours a day you know that yeah that's
for sure yeah okay they definitely stole
the election it's like you know that
bill because you watched Newsmax after
dinner like you can't be that certain
you can be skeptical as hell yeah no
doubt I'll say one more thing about Fox
News and I think one of the biggest
reasons why they decided to settle
because the future of their brand hinges
on their personalities whether it's
Tucker whether it's Hannity whether it's
Laura Ingram the Murdoch's the whole
family the last thing that fox needs for
their brand is talker on the
hand on the Bible and on the mobile on
the Bible swearing under oath it's the
last thing that they need for their
brand let's pay this fine it sucks get
it over with live to fight another day
the last thing they needed to do was
drag on and on and on and have all their
stars all their Executives on the trial
I I think there's something else here
and what it is is most folks probably
don't understand the calculus of
settlement the calculus of settlement is
about time it's about reputation and
more than anything discovery
when you're on the stand if you go all
the way to court goes on the stand the
other side can say I want to ask about
your HR policies and your lawyer says
wait wait we object this is not related
know your honor it goes to their
willingness to allow people to do this
or this and if you get uh Lachlan and
you get Rupert on the stand and you get
other people what happens is you can do
a tremendous amount of exploratory
questioning that is actually not
directly related to the suit if you can
simply get the judge to agree with you
that he'll allow the allow the line of
questioning and so there is not a media
company anywhere in the known universe
that wants any of their Executives on
the stand they MSNBC doesn't want the
producers for Rachel Maddow on there
have you ever been in contact were you
in contact with uh Hillary Clinton's
campaign on a daily basis and talking
about this they don't want that well
these 10 emails say they were
great perspective this says Jim D
podesta says that he he reached out to
Rachel and Rachel covered imagine we
have the tape here Rachel said this
which comes right out of dipodusta's
email to you of that morning at 10 16
a.m that is not what anybody wants I do
not believe that the media industry
although their news divisions are
cheering what just happened to FOX I
don't think anybody in news actually
thinks this is a good settlement and Pat
I showed this uh to Rob I sent this to
you in slack about what pisses me off
about the double standard and the left
is like what because it's all the left
talking crap these are this is a video
of all the Democrats during uh Trump's
uh election went about how all these
machines and all this voting thing is
all suspect can you can you play it Rob
computer voting because it's so
vulnerable we need to look at all the
voting machines every Secretary of State
needs to be you know assisted in making
sure that they are not being uh hacked
and and attacked I continue to think
that our voting machines are too
vulnerable researchers have repeatedly
demonstrated that ballot recording
machines and other voting systems are
susceptible to tempering even hackers
with limited prior knowledge tools and
resources are able to breach voting
machines isn't that weird is this weird
2018 electronic voting machines in
Georgia and Texas deleted votes for
certain candidates or switch votes from
one candidate to another the biggest
seller of voting machines is doing
something that violates cyber security
101 directing that you install remote
access software which would make a
machine like that you know a magnet for
frogsters and hackers these voting
machines can be hacked quite easily
really easily hack into them it makes it
seem like all these states are doing
different things but in fact three
companies are controlling this it is the
individual boating machines that some
pose that pose some of the greatest
risks there are a lot of states that are
dealing with Antiquated machines
are being hacked the workers were able
to easily hack into an electronic voting
machine it was possible to switch votes
43 of American voters use voting
machines thank you that researchers
is going after Trump you're hearing them
while the sudden is it all good and you
should believe in it and look at um
they're still going mother they're still
talking about it but it's one side it's
okay but the other side it's not it's
not it's not the law you you let's let's
let's put a pin in this and come back
Pat in one year I believe this is the
law of unintended consequences on Parade
I want to come back in a year I'm not
trying to stop a conversation right now
but I'd love to come back in a year
replay the last 20 minutes this podcast
and look at all the stuff that's come
out since then because folks this is the
law of unintended consequences the water
is coming down and it's gonna go over
the waterfall can you like tell it to
the average sixth grader on what what
you're trying to say yeah a year from
now we are going to look back and we are
going to see multiple lawsuits because I
think Trump is going to come out and do
things we're going to see other lawsuits
against other media companies and other
settlements and we are going to see just
what has just happened here uh like
Portland Oregon and all the store
closings and everything down there they
allowed all this stuff during the woke
time pat they defunded their police
department and now look a year later you
look back and you say that didn't work
and so that's that's an unintended
consequence by the way it's like you you
ratted on your sister you got her in
trouble with your dad and then four
weeks later you and your brother got
home at 1am a.m and then your dad says
well I grounded her for two weeks I'm
grounding you for two weeks yeah by the
way I would actually love to see that I
would love to see CNN have to pay a half
a billion dollars or whatever the amount
is for the lies that they have told of
course I think if you're going to call
out one side you need to call out both
both sides have been peddling
disinformation or fake news and right
now Fox is paying but I think at some
point CNN should have to pay I mean
something out of the way it works CNN is
the king of fake news Trump put them on
blast in just one but Pat I think you
nailed it Donald Trump should one I
don't know what he's waiting for should
100 percent go after not just CNN MSNBC
all of them it was bro people still
today I have people Pat from tally that
are like he colluded he's a Russian ass
how much did Stormy Daniels pay uh to
Trump what was it all around I think
like 500 000 she should be paid to him
yeah she just paid him another 120
million
paid all of it before tab Rob What's Her
tab oh yeah Adam Her tab right now was
ordered to pay Trump's attorney fees of
120 000. this is a couple oh yeah but
this is no that's not all of it it's 500
000 plus this yeah it's a lot so Stormy
Daniels has to pay Trump quite a a lot
of money yeah but here's the point the
point is the same way stormy had to pay
her stormy had to pay him uh for you
know
when's the last time you heard that
story though for a girl that has as much
you know she's a porn star right that's
what she did yeah she's paying Trump
when's the last time a porn star
I know dude that's like bragging rights
you're at a bar the guy says let me tell
you who I just hooked up with this porn
star this Trump says let me tell you how
much a pornstar had to pay me for me to
for Earth to hook up with me and I gave
her a terrible Yelp review
but but here's the part if that's the
case he needs to he needs to play in the
offensive he needs to play knowing him I
wouldn't be surprised if he does okay
he's already suing Michael Cohen for a
billion dollars
he's one of the most litigious guys in
New York a wise member was 3 300 lawsuit
I don't know the exact number he's been
in a lot of lawsuits in New York the
last 50 years if you can type how many
lawsuits has Trump been a part of I
don't know why I remember number 3300
it's a big number uh uh uh what is the
number total no no no this is not like
Book of Revelation go ahead he's gonna
say A wise man once said at the
beginning of the new year this is the
year of Investigations it is
investigations pbd it is not going to
slow down it is not gonna slow down okay
border crossing search 23 in March
nearly 200
000 people uh crossing a border uh
migrant encounters at the U.S Mexico
border increased by 23 in March compared
to February with a total of 191 900
arrivals counted right the U.S Customs
and Border Protection the agency
stressed that the March Figures were
down compared to march of the previous
year and that the majority six to nine
percent of the encounters were single
adults acting CBP commissioner Troy
Miller noted that the agency continues
to work around the clock to maintain
border security they emphasize that the
increase in immigrants and migrant
encounters between February and March is
typically as winter temperatures rise
and a 23 increase was significantly less
than the 34 surge of the same month last
year this by the way how big of an issue
Tom will this be for 2024 elections this
is going to be huge because you know
what's not being covered is the the
crime that uh Arizona and uh New Mexico
and Texas are facing if you take a look
and by the way Greg Abbott
um regardless of what you feel about
Texas regardless of you about Greg
Abbott he has been very accurately
describing the statistics of crime that
are happening in the border cities with
all of these folks coming over looking
for looking for the jobs looking for a
place or they're coming over here
because they're on a mission because
they're part of a drug cartel and
they're part of a distribution expansion
and so this is going to be a huge issue
in Arizona and New Mexico and you're
seeing it you're seeing it pat in things
moving because Kerry Lake was just part
of it Kerry lake is not Kerry Lake
without part of the immigration issue
that was creating problems not not the
racist anti-immigration because we all
came from somewhere my folks are from
Canada your folks from some point were
from Israel I mean look look where you
from Iran you know you wherever you were
from from New York
you know it's like whoever this guy's
from no but we're all here from someone
give us your tired report we all come
from somewhere but the problems that
were happening in Arizona that led to
the emergence Kerry Lake and so you take
a look at this is still a huge huge
issue and by the way these folks need
housing so to all of the people in
Hollywood Music Industry kept
threatening to move to Canada will you
please go we need room yeah exactly
imagine let's not let's not lie to
ourselves these are like we talked about
it before these are all votes for
Democrats because I don't know if you
watched mayorkas has been on on like the
judicial house and all these hearings
where they're like the Republicans are
grilling in they keep telling them about
all these numbers all all these kids
that are coming over Pat they're making
these 15 year old kids work and he's
like what about the labor laws and and
no answers no straight answer he always
floats around it it's a crisis like look
at dude 23 surge in marched 100 and they
want these people here what about all
the kids they're actually having kids
work all these kids that are
disappearing that are coming over the
Border because they're unaccompanied uh
children has skyrocketed and it's like
the left doesn't care all they have to
say is oh no we look we love them we
care they don't give a damn bro those
are going to be votes trust me those are
votes of the for the Democratic party
because they're going to remember those
people who let them in because you know
what they're going to say the
Republicans said no no but remember
Democrats they wanted you to come in
here so did you see the exchange uh
between Holly and Alejandro mayorkas I
love see that or no let me send this to
you Rob I'm gonna I'm gonna text it to
you if you can pull this up it's a very
interesting exchange that these guys
have uh obviously he gets pushed pretty
hardcore uh let me see if this is the
one
yeah I think this may be the one and he
never answers one question right he
never answers one one straight answer
ever he's majorca's he's he's just he
has that smirk on his face because he
knows what's going on bro he was put
there to just let everybody come in wait
one second when I'm placenting to you
not that one play this one I'm about to
send to you today Holly's and Holly's a
pretty you know he he's a gangster he
loves him back down I just sent you the
second one played the second one from
C-SPAN he's OG on what these guys are
doing it's just kind of like well you
know uh look you know you are misstating
the facts so terribly you know yeah it's
um a sense of casualness with the issue
that's going on at the border but I do
believe this is also going to be another
one of those top five issues that will
be brought up in the election in 2024.
can make that bigger and
yeah this guy he doesn't play games
Holly goes afterwards again as shelters
filled with children
the administration began loosening
vetting restrictions and urging case
managers to speed the process along you
have at every stage
facilitated
certain day indentured servitude of
minor children yep why should you not be
impeached for this
I look forward to discussing this issue
further because you are
misstating the facts uh so uh terribly I
am reading you the facts from articles
in the news and your usual modus
operandi is what you're doing again
today was just to deny deny deny why
have you permitted 345
000 children to come into this country
unaccompanied why have you permitted
thousands of them to be abused and
exploited yep Senator what we do is we
enforce the law but let me just say this
yeah no answer not one Pad
but guys imagine for everybody that's
watching this too go and watch these in
full length he doesn't answer one
question the Republicans the only ones
holding his foot to the fire you know
what the Democrats are saying when they
ask them questions they're like so you
know you're letting these people you're
helping these people what's your
favorite video game like stuff like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah like it's like it's
insane and again these are gonna be one
of those points where when it comes to
voting time people are going to say
listen look at the border look how many
are coming over look at the search but
dude by that time it might be it might
be too late so it is a real issue though
by the way I I saw the uh if you have
Megan Kelly's clip Megan Kelly responds
and and she's furious with some of the
stuff that's going on if you have a
video she did not hold back and man I I
hope I hope the Megan Kelly who is a dog
she's a fighter when I say dog I mean
like a good fighter fighter like [__]
she's an attorney she is a beast I hope
she she by the way she goes after
everybody so it's not if you want Megan
Kelly you're gonna get all of Megan
Kelly and and I don't mind it I think
she's tough and I think we need her
voice and what is that what did she say
check this out look at what she says
here Nike sponsoring Dylan Mulvaney now
no not this one this is not the one nope
this is not the one it's what she talked
about yesterday with the sports Bros
with not not just the sports bras she
says I go to the uh gynecologist and I'm
having my and she says how frustrating
it is to go through that and this girl
is saying you you don't have a vagina
you have a hole okay and she just went
off
oh man I hope I thought Rob had it no we
can go to the next story I'll look for
and I'll send it to you yeah it's a very
very uh okay I'll promise to talk about
it here today we got 15 more minutes
we'll go to another store and we'll come
back to this so 50 state report
GOP led states are in best economic
conditions okay GOP led states are
invest that's not if she didn't have
that top on I can tell you he's actually
had a navy blue top on okay so the
American legislative exchange Council
released a report ranking all 50 states
best awards for economic conditions
based on 15 metrics mostly related to
state tax environment with Utah ranking
as a number one state followed by North
Carolina and Arizona
republican-led States largely filled the
better parts of the ranking while
democrat-led States fell to the bottom
with the top 10 states almost entirely
being republican-led and the bottom 10
states all Democratic led the bottom of
the ranking is occupied by Democrat by
New York Vermont Minnesota Jersey
Illinois while the top half of states
offer more Economic Opportunity and a
better quality of life as taxpayers
continue to move towards states that
have a lower cost of life and it can get
it right with policy can you pull up
this uh the ranking there Rob if you
have the story if you can pull up this
article this the epoch times story with
uh the title if you just want to Google
it the title says 50 state report GOP
LED if you just type that it'll come out
50 state report GOP LED and it should be
an Epoch times yeah if you just put that
it should come up there you go right
there
so if you can go to the ranking I want
them to see the ranking keep going lower
we can subscribe later to this yeah keep
going lower lower lower
uh there you go okay the full rank in
the states Utah Carolina Arizona Idaho
Oklahoma Wyoming Indiana North Dakota
Florida Nevada top ten okay then
Tennessee Georgia Texas South Dakota
Arkansas pretty much the nine out of the
top ten I think the number was is all
Republican let's now go to the bottom
ten go to the bottom ten is what you're
looking at New York is the lowest
worse for best economic condition
Vermont Minnesota Jersey Illinois
California Maine Oregon Hawaii Maryland
Rhode Island all Democrat pretty blue
Connecticut New Mexico so this right
here States if you want a Fighting
Chance
with your savings with taxes with growth
with you to have a shot at having a
you know a retirement one day where you
can retire with dignity and enjoy the
times and have a fighting shot at saving
money having a decent weekend doing all
of that stuff red States offer that more
than blue states do period and economy
is something that is common sense it's
math it's data it's not just ideas it's
not lip service nope there's economy
there is data and that can be argued Tom
what are your thoughts about this story
here well I I look at it and I say God
if I'm blue what is the highest ranking
State and you know I'm thinking of
climate and stuff and it's the uh the
vast Wasteland that is Nevada is number
10. so I thought that was sort of
amusing and then to get to another blue
State I think I had to get all the way
down to number 16 Michigan so surprising
that Michigan was like number 16. but I
look at this and it basically just says
that when when you favor three
principles Liberty free enterprise and
capitalism as your tenants of Freedom
look what happens look what happens
economically in your state and you know
what strong economics lead too
proper coffers full of properly taxed
people not excessively taxed and you can
turn that into education you can turn it
into infrastructure I look at this and
it's more than just the economic
Condition it's also what that economic
condition enables as a state that has so
much else to offer it's shocking and I
go say what is the worst Red State you
could live in it's number 36 uh Nebraska
Red State and that so there's 14 blue
States behind Nebraska I was just
shocked looking at this at how Stark it
is when you make an objective assessment
of what's the what's the playing field
to allow a great economy and you know
the principles of Freedom Liberty free
enterprise entrepreneurship it's it's so
clear Adam how you process this because
typically when you see numbers like this
you come back and you say
uh show me the bottom 10 states
like that I fully agree
if you're going to look at your money
you kind of got to look at it
holistically you know one of the things
I always say is that you have offense
and you also have defense right so you
might be able to put the most points on
the board in New York we just
established they had the most
millionaires of any other state in the
country California their GDP is greater
than pretty much most countries
um but just because you make a ton of
money you know then there's the defense
which is your expenses your expenditures
and how much money you're leaking in
cost of living in taxes and over
regulation and being a non-friendly
business climate I.E New York so if you
look at the it's not just making all the
money because clearly you can make more
money in States like New York like in
California in Massachusetts but you're
going to be spending a lot more to live
there so you're going to find that
healthy balance and that's why I think a
lot of people are moving to Florida
yeah and those those other company
what you want to do with that voice
still yeah yeah do you think you should
move to Florida yeah change the voice
yeah if you make all the money in New
York and then you move to Florida and
you pay no taxes yeah that's it escape
and then go to Puerto Rico by the way
what's crazy is what people don't
realize is Adam's voice on the podcast
is not his real voice this is Adam's
real voice
yeah see
that's right Tom go ahead so Tom
actually I look at this uh Bill Clinton
in real life he just has this you know
the biz doc voice here go ahead Tom go
show them what you got can you tell us
in your Billboards and then the interns
you know what when I look at this I to
what you just said New York has the most
millionaires for now California is the
number seven economy in the world for
now because we're seeing it we're seeing
the drainage there's a leak at the
bottom of them and five years from now
what is that going to look like but
that's very true a tremendous amount of
wealth was made without Silicon Valley
we don't have the iPhone and and tons of
other products that have made life
better without the Venture Capital
industry you don't have electric cars
and a lot of things that have made life
better California is not all bad this is
talking about right now what is the
leadership of these states done to give
an economic playing field now to keep it
and these guys are deep into the second
half of their game and they're losing it
and they're fumbling the ball and that's
why people are leaving great sports
analy that's great Sports and obviously
Tom that's a great time you did very
good see what's this guy gonna do when
you talk like that on a date how do the
cruise oh my God I talk like this Dave
Chappelle did amazing look at this guy
he doesn't know the meaning of the word
Fair yeah if you look at this report
card
well I'm trying to see if he found it or
not if if I expect you something but
that's from two months ago there's
another thing that just came up from a
day ago which I'll find here for you did
you see the one I just sent you
this is just Megan Kelly I I I love what
she says here as well you can play this
one I'll send the other one about a man
will never be a woman is which a man
cannot become a woman a woman cannot
become a man that's that's from a day
ago but I want you to play this first so
watch this one Watch this once 42
seconds if we don't find our voices and
start speaking up against this nonsense
we can kiss every woman's face goodbye
we can kiss women's rights goodbye
Robert uh uh uh did I not text it to you
very fun to talk in that voice oh God
Peabody give it a shot why are you why
are you uh uh misleading people well we
know that's your real voice why are you
doing that hey girl come on here acting
like you have this flawless Voice or
whatever and it's like James Cagney
1955. yeah that's what it is
okay go ahead Rob if you got that guy
why is it making my blood boil that
Kristen claims to have a gynecologist
part of it is I just actually went to
the gynecologist it's never particularly
Pleasant the exam doesn't feel
particularly good the pap smear is very
uncomfortable no one looks forward to
that we actually have things we need to
worry about like ovarian cancer things
that are particular to that exam and
that relationship that no [__] man is
ever going to have all right so that guy
doesn't have a gynecologist that guy has
a hole that a surgeon created at best
there are things that make women special
and there are things that we've overcome
and that we must overcome as women in
order to thrive in them in this life
whether it's the threat of sexual
violence or you know being attacked as
we walk home from college bars to our
dorms the fears that you have when you
go to the gynecologist all those things
they're baked in and it's part of what
makes women so incredible and strong and
you can't just become one and take all
of our things because you did or did not
have a surgery or you put on a dress
it's it doesn't work like that
spoken like a true woman I love this I
love her let me tell you how necessary a
voice like Megan Kelly is right now in
this insane situation where you know who
needs to speak more about this trans
situation women I feel you know who
needs to speak up more about this
Chelsea Handler boss babe I don't need
no man no thing I don't need no kids
mothers okay you know who you need to
speak about the feminization of men and
these [__] boys that this that we're
creating this toxic masculinity women
that like real men and someone like
Megan Kelly I think represents all of
that and then some and her voice is very
necessary I agree and well maybe we get
around but ask you a question why is it
that it's just this is my it's my
opinion as much as you know you well as
much as you say that then why is it that
more women like Chelsea Handler are
turned on by you yeah they love oh they
love them you know
it's because here's how I talk to
Chelsea I say
I agree with you I 100 agree with her
but is it just me or or are we just
seeing the voices that are sticking up
for these people it's only from the
right the left they they can't even
Define what a woman is they ask the the
who's that the girl that went up for um
uh scotus she couldn't even they're like
what's a woman she goes I'm not a
biologist I can't why is the left so one
is it just pandering because they well
it is changing we want to see what
happened with uh Anna kasparian right
who's the co-host of The Young Turks I
didn't see well she's she's basically
saying I'm a mother I'm not a birthing
person yeah I refuse to just
this ridiculous terminology that you
want me to use I'm a mother yeah and I'm
not going to be ashamed for being a
mother I'm not going to start using
phrases like birthing person yeah okay
I'm talking about but that's what's but
that's that's it's starting to change
that's one person but I'm talking about
the Biden Administration everybody in
the what none of them they're worshiping
these people they're gonna start
bringing a bunch of these tickets but
here's what here's what I think about
them let them do it exactly I think you
let him do it and I think election time
you're going to see some of the people
that are going to say look Common Sense
eventually catches up okay when we're
kids we don't have a lot of common sense
we think our parents are idiots we think
they have no clue what the hell they're
talking about and then the more and more
you age the more and more you realize
you know it's kind of these old people
living there they're kind of smarter
than me okay it's kind of annoying
Common Sense eventually prevails with
parent kid relation if you have good
parents not telling every you know
father ran away and I'm talking about
you know Common Sense prevails when it
comes down to things like this election
you're hoping that eventually this also
prevails I want to play one more clip by
Megan Kelly then one more clip by Pierce
Morgan debate which is phenomenal and it
will wrap up the podcast you guys got to
see this book play this next clip with
Megan Kelly oh Megan you know go making
making first I send that one to you as
well okay go ahead people like Riley
Gaines the swimmer we discussed chased
into some room as a kidnap victim
because she tries to stand up for
fairness in sports and they've had it
they've seen kids who instead of getting
on a psychological care only get
affirmed you're right you are a boy
you're not a girl you should go on Cross
hormones immediately they get sterilized
they go right to puberty blockers right
across sex hormones and they are sterile
not only that no orgasms for them in
their future nice is that informed
consent for a 14 year old who's going
through bodied issues and that's all
what she really needed was a good honest
therapist no we're standing up and we're
fighting not because of some stupid
group that decided to make a wedge issue
out of it but because the leftists have
lost their mind and some of us still
have a Tethered to the truth men cannot
become women women cannot become men
biological sex is real if you've got
issues with respect to your gender you
can work them out on your own time and
manifest them however you want doesn't
make you a woman seeing
people think about her I want to remind
you of something this is a lawyer she
went to law school and then she was
working for Jones day and she was the uh
one of her key clients was a company
called Experian credit company and so
what you see here is well reasoned
argument this is not a lunatic this is
well recent argument and this is exactly
if this is what you're thinking and this
is what you're feeling this is what you
should be expressing with friends and
family maybe not with that tone but
expressing it with friends and family I
am I'm talking to my daughters they're
asking me questions I'm talking to
people not just at church where people
think a lot the way I do but other
people I run into a recent thing I'm not
hiding my opinion I'm not sitting behind
anything and this is this is she's a
flag carrier for what we should be
saying because there's truth in there
this is not her lunatic opinion this is
truth yeah no that's great and by the
way yesterday this happened yesterday or
two days ago on Bill Maher Katie Porter
and Pierce Morgan went back and forth
and if you haven't seen this Pierce
pierces her you gotta see this so watch
this go ahead play this to have a civil
debate nobody including Riley Gaines who
I disagree with strongly should be
disagree with that of interest
um I I think that it should be up to
sporting bodies to make the decisions
about who what if she said that's
actually wrong
I think that what she has done is try to
turn this we talked about people you
know becoming using things to kind of
get likes and get clicks that's not what
she's doing I mean I've got no truck
right against personally but all I've
seen to do is stand up for women's
rights to fairness and equality so she
has she actually competed against Leah
Thomas and it was obviously unfair Leo
Thomas won one of the races in the NCAA
championships by 50 seconds against a
bunch of biological females who simply
couldn't keep up that cannot be right it
cannot be fair that is something common
sense is clapping yeah common sense is
clapping yeah bodies should be dealing
with and by the way Riley is speaking up
for herself
and that is her prerogative and I
respect no she's speaking up pretty much
every female athlete in the world yes
Common Sense yes
in the early 70s was something that was
a it was a major event in feminism that
we finally have this law that says at
colleges right and title I do but
definitely colleges women women sports
have to be given equal to men's sports
so that women aren't you know and this
led to the WNBA and lots of other stuff
this seems to be the opposite of that it
seems to be so many instances I think
where wokeness is the opposite of what I
grew up as living right
liberalism was let's give the women an
equal shot this is let me put a bail in
the in the swimming pool with the women
I don't get it it's crazy and meanwhile
trans people who genuinely want to
compete at Athletics and swimming or
whatever it may be they they're the ones
who are suffering here they need to be
found a way to compete fairly and justly
well what's your answer then I think
there's one or two answers I think they
either compete against their biological
sex as many of them did before or you
create an entirely new category for a
transgender Common Sense collapse again
no argument is continue to allow more
and more trans athletes to start
decimating women's records in some cases
irrevocably it's just not fair okay I
got it by the way she has nothing to say
period nothing to say that's the part of
my Common Sense there is nothing you can
say about what he just said in that
debate right there two men
defended biological women were a
biological woman defended a biological
male yes tell me that's not confusing
upside down at the end of the day a
woman at no danger of having an abortion
was silence that was perfect two men are
telling a woman what real women should
be doing that is so freaking on point
that is when confusion people sit there
and say yeah this doesn't make sense
ma'am yes yeah and if that makes sense I
watched Bill Maher every Friday night uh
well usually I watch it Saturday
mornings I'm out Friday night but I
always watch the show and this audience
is 80 90 liberal leftists they're I've
been there I've been on that they're not
exactly Maga okay so but when exactly so
but when they're clapping and giving
rounders of Applause for basically what
he's standing up for common sense
they're just like yeah look at me this
is this is so far-fetched what else
you know we need a value payment Pat we
need we need the common sense Roundup
and once a week let's grab all these
clips together that are all common sense
yeah and let's put them back to back to
back and let valuetainers everywhere go
look at us and and we'll curate it you
know and I love movie clips that do this
too you know you you go back to Jaws it
says Hoopa you go in the water cage goes
in the water you'll go in the cage and
the Sharks and water okay you know and
the the speech from Scent of a Woman
there is so many examples of common
sense that we could put out here both
from film and from real life people need
to allow themselves to be heard when
they have an opinion of Common Sense and
do not allow the whoa I love it don't
allow woke life to cause you to be
silent start with your friends and
family don't stand on a table at lunch
and get fired at work but start with
your friends and family and get put
Common Sense back on the table folks we
gotta go in the water is what we got to
do you guys have a great weekend
tomorrow I will be in LA
and Saturday and then I think we do have
podcasts next Tuesday are we doing
podcasts next Tuesday we're not doing
podcasts next Tuesday no next Thursday
so we don't have anything next week
SLS that's right I've got SLS at I got
you which by the way at SLS we're going
to make the announcement of the guest at
the Vault and people gonna freaking flip
out when we make that announcement
anyways uh folks have a great weekend
enjoy it and we will do this again A
week we're gonna miss you for a week but
we'll do it again next Thursday take
care everybody calm down